[Musique]
vous voulez contrôler votre vie mais
dans la vie tout n'est pas quantifiable
vous ne pourrez pas éternellement
maîtriser votre environnement
faites-vous peur pendant ses congés
d'accord oui
cette carte est un billet d'entrée pour
les ex les promeneurs soyez le premier à
vous échapper de la plus immersive des
salles et empoché un million de dollars
alors le jeu commence quand
je crois que c'est le scalp room
cherchons des indiciels jardin disent
tout ce qui ressemble à une pièce de
puzzle ou à un code
on dirait le bouton de réglage d'un four
ça chauffe on dirait excusez moi on
aimerait avoir notre indice ça c'est
grave flippant je rêve où il fait encore
plus chaud je m'en sors d'ici c'est par
unaï 451 j'ai pigé
ça c'est ce que j'appelle tony mère
surtout complètement débile
c'était réel question idiote
on est vraiment dehors la plus vite en
droit résolu ça plus vite on se cassera
d'ici
si c'est juste rassam
[Musique]
ils nous observent iseppi nos moindres
faits et gestes
ils savent absolument tout sur moi
c'était mon lit d'hôpital yens bien
aussi ils ont créé ce jeu tournus vous
avez déjà vu des choses apparaître comme
par magie
je ne suis pas en train de rêver
survivre est un choix
certains restaient bas certaines vidéos
voilà pourquoi ils ont choisi un bo
[Musique]